what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here today john how's
it going i am great grand old time we
are going to have today with house of
the dragon episode 2 today ladies and
gentlemen please go ahead and leave a
like that would be so appreciated also
subscribe click the notification bell to
get notified when reactions for the next
hotd is up gonna be aiming to cover lotr
as well the pg version of this
and the just as agreeable version two
well guys uh full length reaction watch
along so we sync up with your own copy
the time code over at our patreon page
for super sexy rejects cover a bunch of
shows over there exclusively or the
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included and the team at prepper of
course thank you for helping us edit
down these highlights let's get to it
oh it's that that crab guy they
mentioned from last the pirate yeah
oh my god that is disgusting
[Music]
it's yeah the screams alone if you've
something to discuss lord i want to know
what is to be done about my ships and my
men the crown will compensate you for
your ship and crew and make an offering
to the men's i don't want compensation
i want my wife to be queen
i've sent 10 boys to pentos and volantis
to see if we might find common cause
ships and men are at the
ready the step stones will be settled oh
she's strategy you have dragon right his
father yes
flex that power i only meant that we
should at least perhaps
there's some better use for the
princess's talents your grace
get out of that chair
son of the steward of the lord of
blackheath
you saw combat in the stormlands i
fought for a year as a foot soldier
against the dornish incursions
i choose sir kristen cole he just
happens to be the best looking one too
and uh you know he fought against my
brother in one so
cut cousin
my father should be defended by a man
who's normal combat
should he not
of course princess
let us plant sir kristin's investiture
then
i don't like how insanely logical she is
be more passionate and blind
over a thousand dragons
a navy large enough to span the seas of
the world
the glory of old valyria will never be
seen again
oh wow
foreshadowing yeah
this guy's all foreshadowing
you do not mention our talks to renero
do you
no you're grace
fear would limit our options moving
forward you know
i find this is a way to be with my
mother
i know it sounds foolish
i don't think it's foolish
because i thought you might try
if not for me then
perhaps for them
i have your queen
i will not reflect on my dead mother
[Music]
i like that shot a lot
i want him to see me as more than his
little girl
my own father does not know the language
of girls either
when i wish to talk with him
i know that i must make the effort
thank you
they are going to become enemies just
don't tell me if i'm wrong
just let us enjoy it
i fear that the eyes of our enemies are
presently fixed on the red keep a girl
has been named heir to the iron throne
the king's brother so disinherited has
claimed the targaryen seat on
dragonstone and now a foreign power has
established a colony in our most
critical shipping lane
he makes a lot of great points seriously
why isn't this guy higher up
our daughter elena
unite the two great surviving valyrian
houses with the targaryen dragons and
the valarian fleet bound in blood you
can show the realm that the crown's
strongest days are
ahead behind
damn oh boy
it hasn't even been half a year since
emma passed the realm expects you to
take a new wife sooner or later grace
come on alliston
yes
we should be free to speak our minds to
one another
you can say whatever you'd like you are
the
can't hear king crickets
yeah
today at
small council paid no mind
i i thought i might have had some
insights i'm young but
you will learn
and there goes the conversation
another six months and do it again
maggots for treatment
that's not ominous
whatsoever stop the advance of the rock
so it's not grayscale he proposed a
marriage
the lady elena to combine the strength
of our houses and demonstrate my rain's
strongest days are ahead such matters
must be discussed with a small council
that is what i'm doing
presently
i uh
dearly loved my own lady wife
and to be compelled to
replace her for duty's sake
you are the king
but i do not envy you
you're clever
slime
i love how subtle he is about these
things
unite the houses
would be a great honor
to join our houses as they were in all
valeria
i would give you many children of pure
valerian blood so that we might
strengthen the royal line and the realm
it's so uncomfortable what your father
told you to say
oh she improvised that
she wants this more than he does i
understand the order of things
i'm not sure you do
if you mean to elicit some anger from me
you should know that you're failing
princess
quite the opposite i already love this
scene the men of the realm already had
their opportunity to appoint a ruling
queen at the great council and they
denied it
they denied you princess rhaenys
but they bent the knee to me and called
me heir to the throne do you remind your
father's men of that as you carry their
cups
well played
yeah
battle of wits
men would sooner put the round to the
torch
and see a woman ascend the iron throne
and your father is no fool
i i want more scenes with them i know
that was great
do a bottle episode i'm sure that she is
good and kind
and that she will enjoy your company as
i have
oh my god power move
call this a hail mary
it's a new pinky
oh
very kind gesture allison
very kind
fictional historical time period
adjust your head correct
this relationship is appropriate for the
time
snap
oh jesus
[Music]
that's even worse the prince left a
missive which i believe might explain
it is the pleasure of damon targaryen
the prince of dragonstone and rightful
heir to the iron throne
yep
take a second wife in the tradition of
old valeria
she is to assume the title lady missouri
no
the prince
has invited you to his wedding your
grace oh
man
demon latest
clever girls
[Music]
[Music]
i will go to dragonstone and drag david
back to place justice
damon is without limit
let me go to dragonstone
she's let her go to dragonstone that was
cool they actually heard her out
that's a good question
why didn't we think of that
why do you destroy yourself
will you see the king tonight
if you wish it i've assembled 20 of your
best household guards my lord hand i
don't understand why you hurt yourself
you've seen the king right
you better come back married
dragonstone
[Music]
let's go
you're to relinquish the dragon's egg
disband your army and leave dragonstone
by order of his grace king where is the
king i don't see him his grace would
never lower himself to entertain such a
mama's face
oh boy
even that guy knows
so kristen cole my prince ah yes
apologies i couldn't recall
perhaps my prince recalls when i knocked
him off his horse
[Laughter]
this is a truly pathetic show dave with
every breath you saw your name your
house and your brother's reign our love
does not know titles and traditions
such good attitude i know
you've come for the egg
here it is
uh-oh
are you mad
you've never survived this well happily
neither would you
to choose violence here is to declare
war against your king
wonderful
even if it ends in the death of your
unborn child and its mother
i don't think we'll be fighting today
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
yeah
what's gonna happen all of you
see the [ __ ] steel
oh oh
oh
jesus
dude
oh netball chills
[Laughter]
i'm digging it
sorry
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i thought i was pregnant this whole time
it's gonna be an awkward conversation
when i get back to the throne room
if you wish to be restored as uh you'll
need to kill me
so do it
and be done with all this bother
you're more man than anyone here
[Music]
damn
think fast
[Music]
well done princess
[Music]
and that's how it's done
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean there we were we were about to
kill each other and then she just showed
up on a track and it was awesome
she was like kill me now and he was like
well fine i'm taking the edges through
the track
walked right back inside like a [ __ ]
oh man
that was unexpected yeah yeah it was the
first time in a while i was like i don't
know what's about to happen
you're safe with me i swear it you are
targaryen you can afford to play your
stupid games with the king but i cannot
i didn't come into your service wanting
gold
the power
do you know who you're standing up to
you should wed lana velary on your grace
save lord call us and fix him at your
side
permanently as an ally
god so many tough decisions i know
i feel bad
from dragonstone
who else is undermining my authority
actually it could
maybe be perceived that way
your grace
you disobeyed me
you deliberately disobeyed me it's
exactly the first thought
and retrieve the egg with our bloodshed
a feat i'm not sure so otto could have
accomplished alone
i sometimes forget how alike you both
were
oh
i wish i had known better
what to say to you in the aftermath i
struggled to realize that my daughter
had so quickly become a woman grown
i could never replace your mother
no more than i intend to replace you as
heir
oh
and by marrying again i may begin to
ensure that we are better defended you
are the king
and so your first duty is to the realm
yeah yeah yeah
put a little stark love in the
targaryens in this show huh
some actual like
actual warmth warmth and compassion yeah
love and tenderness these are actual
humans they actually do love each other
and this is a complicated situation for
them yeah
i have decided
to take a new wife
this is a mislead
i'm afraid it could be
i intend to marry
[Music]
the lady allison hightower
what oh look at otto's face it worked oh
my god
my house
is valerian
the greatest power in the realm
and i am your king
look on error's face when she realized
it was about to be said yeah what the
shit's been going on
you what
you and you and what
oh
what a deceit
[Music]
dude she's gonna go hang out with damon
now huh oh this is so complicated i love
it yeah
that's what we wanted this is so
complicated
torture these characters oh
david as valerian's origins reach back
to old valyria
more ancient even than house targaryen
according to some texts oh my god he's
talking to damon he's we're talking to
damon dude
i've always thought of you and i as
having been
made from the same cloth oh god it is
oh yeah
oh yeah
oh so many nipple chills this episode
we're both men who have had to cut our
own way through the world
we've been passed over
too often
now marry my daughter
you've heard of the troubles in the step
steps
some mirish prince is feeding westerosi
sailors to the crabs
i've been petitioning the king to send
my name oh
but he's denied me
and it was never my brother's strongest
trade
what
being king
oh it's not wrong
peter is backed by powerful entities
within the free cities who wish to see
westeros weakened
wow
my house will be crippled
i will not have driftmark beggared while
our king idles himself with feasts and
balls and tornies i will speak of my
brother as i wish
you will not
[Music]
it must be made
forged
[Music]
i love the visuals on this crab guy yeah
oh
[Music]
wow
things are moving fast i know
we're already a six-month jump
i mean when i say fast i'm not saying
rushed
don't know moving out of they're getting
to the point yeah
yeah i love it
all right let's talk about it yeah
i love it good political soap opera
yeah right it's got both the elements
firing on all cylinders it's just that
constant percolating build of everything
and just i love watching [ __ ] build it
and to watch it
like just crumble i love the chaos that
you could feel is coming around the
corner i think like the great days of
game of thrones had always done that so
well
and uh this show's like doing it just
right off the jump from the first
episode into here alliance is switching
around like everything just gone into
disarray all because of this one thing
with the air and i i really love the
ending reveal with
um
cordless cordless cordless cordyceps
cordyceps cordless uh valerian equip
corollarion with with cordless because
at the in the early part of this episode
it's like he's the one warning of a war
but he never thought that he'd be
helping to bring the war yeah he's like
you're not gonna listen to me
then i'm just gonna go start it off
myself yeah headed that way anyway i
think that's such a great reveal and the
alliance between him and damon makes so
much sense and
you know with the way the the first
episode was moved at a bit of a faster
pace but i liked how this one was more
deliberate but really let you simmer in
a lot of the tension
and let you really simmer in a lot of
the
unspoken emotion a lot of the time
there's a lot of good visual language
just working off of the actors
reactions to things yeah what's going on
internally and you could pick up on it
without them having to say it and i
thought that was so strong which so a
lot
was able to be more powerfully
communicated without it having to be
spoken and i think that is such a great
testament to the directing and the
writing of this and of course
like
god like with this cast oh my god it's
so phenomenal and the game of thrones
was so shitty before that yeah they were
all bad
but none of them turned into iconic
characters
and it never got better no no no one's
name comes to mind every time i hear the
theme song i just think that when you
come into when you are um
like we're not we didn't read the book
uh fire blood
and ice and in the name of the father
the songs of all that and stuff
yeah we did we didn't read it uh i mean
got some information on it you know just
to kind of prep some mentality before
going into the show but i'm not like
looking for spoilers yeah a lot of
things are specific just give me some
little history before watching this and
some reminders of game of thrones um but
what this show has succeeded at so well
just right away is
and then saw another ensemble show with
a whole bunch of characters i'm really
interested in and a lot i'm worried
about and everyone's so multi-layered
like the the king
uh viserys
yeah what a dumb move like for him to be
like oh i don't want to cause strain
between you and my daughter
um
and then i'm gonna throw in a random
bomb of not only that it's like it's
your best friend it's a total left turn
and i'm taken now as my stand to marry
for love again even though yeah all all
this has been about not wanting to
replace his his
lost love
well i think the way the targaryens have
always sort of been painted
as you know
especially the ones who are not as
involved with knowing like the true
history of of targaryens from the books
and stuff is a way a lot of it can be
translated or interpreted as
you know like the very surface version
i've always known there's more to it
than this but the very surface version
is kind of ruthless horny people who do
their own family yeah go mad that's
kind of with the interpretation of it
and
you know even when they're talking
there's there's a lot of that coldness
still
present because you know you gotta do
work you gotta do the politics you gotta
do the king's duty
i think they do capture a lot more of
that nuance of
of of emotion uh with these characters
like i loved
the way they i think there was like
three scenes between the king and and uh
renera
yeah i think about three and each one
was like them learning to talk to each
other yeah yeah and all the different
things that that
are said at least individually in that
awkward space between them as they try
to actually connect and the things that
yeah you like you can see the road map
of how all this goes wrong in the
silences between them and i think that's
a really compelling testament to both
the actors and the writing well i think
that last scene was so strong because i
really did show you know in a whole
episode where one of the main focuses
was we got to find this guy king who's a
queen who's he going to marry
and then you have this really sweet
moment of
like oh that love that he had for her
because i didn't start to obviously he
was heartbroken and devastated by the
loss of his wife uh but it was nice to
just be reminded of okay yeah no they
really he really did love her yeah and
it wasn't just some marriage out of duty
that he had to do like he that woman he
really loved
and
then to be manipulated into like he just
he's this guy with like a bunch of
choices and never knows which direction
to take it's like i'm gonna try to make
the right one follow my heart ah damn it
and it doesn't always been manipulated
uh by this whole situation and it and
it's it's crazy like this fight for the
throne and
yeah there's just so much going on yeah
but what i really i i the thing that was
teased to me that i'm really most
looking forward to is the thing with uh
raineris uh rainis rainers rayness
reigns
i can't quit uranus
rhaenyra and reyna and rayness they need
to have more scenes together like i'm
excited to see
how
i feel like that you you know we were
anticipating some kind of you know
growing feud between them obviously
because the position reignus is in but
now that you know rhaenyra has been
is slighted in this way i feel like that
could drive them together well i think
there's a
maybe which would make it even more
um
complex you know if if her husband is
like working with damon
and then she's talking to
renera who
is obviously still loyal so the whole
thing is it's that good tug and pool of
like duty versus war my what i'm feeling
yeah you know
and whether that be i don't agree with
this
position
this alliance or whatever it may be like
rhaenyra for example might be like [ __ ]
my dad um
but i'm not gonna go like side with
damon try to kill him but i don't know
you know yeah like it's it's all it's i
like where it's weaving in and out but
specifically that relationship
you know because
uh reynos has uh oh seriously wouldn't
have heard george r martin to kind of
change up the name
[Laughter]
get a full chart with faces
just like flash cards
learn them all
um with uh with with uranus because
she's someone who has scorned and is so
sad in her ways about here's how it is
and there's a lot of truth to what she
speaks because she has the experience of
not inheriting what should have been
hers
she has
the the knowledge and the in the wisdom
and the years and the pain of it all and
then you got someone like
renera who's um you know while
uh
somewhere ahead of her age and
intelligent she's
still a little bit more
uh
optimistic that she could
make me make things a little bit
different you know so i think there's
the things of
what she can inspire hopefulness of
things that could change of renera and
then raynous who can you know every once
in a while and be like so you've told
japan
i've lived through the sort of political
machinations of this world you have to
be like you shouldn't be surprised when
the world yeah bends you over a bit but
also then yeah rinera can be like but
hey you know without all of that baggage
look what we could do you know see i
think there's a lot they could learn
from each other and a lot they could
have fights about and real debates about
so i think there's a little i think
there's a lot of richness if done
well which that one scene with those two
performers it just demonstrated like man
there's a lot of great things that could
come from just these two interacting
with each other absolutely so i love
that i mean every scene here i thought
was
like this is like a tour de force of
acting to me yeah the the scene in the
with the dragon stone and like that was
the center piece of the episode like
that you wait to see damon till that
moment yeah and i and i'm so excited to
see how they continue to develop him
because the person he shows up as in you
know in public when dealing with the
king or the king's you know small table
people like he's he's one version and
then when you see him in private he's a
different guy and i really loved their
meeting on the bridge and the way she's
just like giving him the opportunity
right there
and
i mean you know it's there obviously
like there's that family tie that's
going to make things more complicated
but i love what is under the surface of
matt smith's performance too because
yeah you see all the wheels turning and
you can tell that maybe even though at
this moment they have so many reasons to
be divided i feel like there's some kind
of unlikely
i don't know if it's a union but i feel
like there may be some unlikely harmony
between rhaenyra and damon to come
maybe i mean i like your point what
you're saying because the first episode
is
you the way you capture damon is the per
is through the perspective of how people
see him
and then this one allowed for a little
bit more private intimate moments and
perhaps some of the more deeper sides
that even
reiner could pick up on about
him you know i could see that he is
there he is just a hurt boy
yeah like he is a hurt violent boy but
he's still a little bit more into the
the the system at hand like i love that
bit with corliss where he's like i can
talk all the [ __ ] i want about the king
but you can't yeah yeah exactly like
that's not something i would have
necessarily expected based off the first
episode
i i i think that's really well fleshed
out and and the way
the way otto is like risa fonz has
always been great yeah ever since the
nodding hill days uh he's always been
great
but
the way these layers just get peeled
back from him because whenever he's put
in a position
i really noticed this about his
performance especially in this episode
whenever he's put in a position where he
has to
argue or
there might be a conflict of interest
amongst council
he kind of the body language and his
tone of voice becomes a little bit meek
yeah you know like
i'm like it's like it doesn't really
seem like you'd be the strongest guy i
don't want to speak out of here yeah
he takes it on it feels so natural like
you're a bit of a wimp aren't you like
it's that's what seemed so endearing
about him in that first episode what
made him like so likable they're like oh
there's a nice one on the team
but then you see that you know he's
actually like the most
strings up there yeah one that's the
thing too
absolutely
and that's the most gratifying thing
across these two episodes thus far is is
like it does feel a bit faster paced
like you said but it also feels like a
return to the form of yeah like the the
scenes where certain characters are
meeting and the tension that comes out
of that and the debates and the
all the different political
considerations you know that stuff is
all as thrilling as when dragons show up
at dragonstone and so yeah
and uh and yeah with hudo hightower it's
like that only you know we're two
episodes in but that doesn't feel rusty
to me that that you would have the seed
planted and you would watch this
machination you get the knowledge that
okay we're six months ahead now and
clearly that seed he planted with
allison is working because yeah now he's
uh for the moment gonna join their two
houses and that could have felt rushed
and it it feels more like a punch here
you know take advantage of the man's
grief yeah i really prayed on that
it's really smart you learn a lot
yeah man
[Music]
if there's one thing game of thrones is
great at is giving you uh characters to
add to the if you idolize this guy
you're missing the point how to be
horrible and influence people
but effectively
yeah that's a good that's that's all i i
mean who plays renara because she's
phenomenal yeah that's millie alcock
right now i i guess they're i can only
assume we're gonna get some sort of time
jump well
i love that this does feel like chapters
that unfold like every episode feels you
call it like chapter one chapter two and
and and with her even at the very
beginning not speaking up i mean trying
to speak up and just being shunned and
being like if we can find a guard
you're just something less than
um
but sometimes it does feel like you she
is so much more logical than everyone
else i know why wouldn't you want to get
a guy who's fought in battle yeah like
that just makes sense doesn't it
that should be your first question for
solid consensus i don't know why they
got the requirements
yeah yeah and even her being like maybe
we should show just a display of power
using our dragons or something to you
know at least force these pirates to
maybe take us a little bit seriously and
i love
that you know i guess to kind of stand
in for instead of the looming threat of
white walkers you have the looming
threat of this like feral pirate gang
who's like leaving people out to be
eaten by crabs crab crab
that's the next one i'm going to have to
commit to memory
crap battle i just keep calling him crap
it's nice i remember they talked about
him in last episode i was like oh yeah
like a cool character but then the way
you see him does does evoke a little bit
more of that um like a more messed up
pirates of the character
right yeah when you're in davey jones
locker yeah like oh this is the r-rated
version of what gore verbinski probably
would want to do like the really messed
up high visual effects budget um but if
it feels so
grimy and an ugly yet you want to you
want to keep watching and it's i want to
see more of this twisted icky nautical
body horror stuff it looks awesome it's
cool to look at it's really cool to look
at and
you're like okay
uh uh
corliss
wants
you know to fight but maybe it'll lead
to an alliance
like when they think oh with the pirates
yeah oh maybe yeah i mean if if they
they speak the language of the sea
together so i'm sure that and i bat
pirates would probably have a reason to
be vexed about dragons so i don't know i
mean i just love a show that feels so
cold yet so goddamn heartbreaking
i love a show that can do both at the
same time because
yeah like this everyone's so layered and
and it seems like ronero is like the
only good person the only one well
that's the only
i feel like i'm missing someone here
is like the only good person well that's
the thing is raniera seems like the only
good person who also is at least smart
and cunning enough about the world she
lives in whereas like i feel like king
viserys is a good guy and he's the one
where i'm like you're just too nice a
guy for the you're not cut out for this
world more like uh you're making some
choices i don't really agree with but
yeah i get it though like i get it yeah
no it's not yeah it's not bad
i feel like they gave a little bit of a
stark touch to them yeah exactly like
allison's not bad i guess there's more
well no she's in a rough position yeah
you can see so much conflict coming out
of that but yeah she's not connected
there's a lot of good people yeah yeah
there's a cluster of good people kristen
sir kristen seems like an all right guy
yeah
you know i mean but hands down whenever
matt smith is on the screen he just he
really just steals the show finally they
got him to like a true project worthy of
his
talents such an antithesis yeah right
yeah the exact opposite of character
it's like he does the things you like
about matt smith
but in the most icky like i don't trust
this guy at all kind of package yeah
what horrific thing is he gonna do next
week because he's phenomenal whenever
he's on screen and i do like because you
like to see him relish but i love when
you do get more of those
quieter moments where he's just
observing and you're watching them so i
really love that little wind and ruffin
touch where you're like they're not
talking but i know what they're thinking
yeah now let's get let's get a synth
score in the next episode slow motion
walking away
with the trout at the track
the dragon
um reveals because i think i feel like
we're gonna get like a cool battle next
week there's gotta be yeah i think next
week's gonna be a [ __ ] in battle it's
gonna be really hard to keep this video
montage
[Laughter]
the thing with the dragons uh oh yeah i
thought that was handled so well at
dragonstone where
you it's like okay is that is that
damon's dragon coming
up oh she's just gonna try like unleash
fire on them
and then for her the way they handled
the reveal that it was her on there oh
that was coming through the clouds like
jaws i like when they choose to speak
valerian yes the choice of that always
feels very apt very deliberate yeah it's
great great moments to choose when it's
speaking
it's it's always like this is real talk
right now
yeah yeah we're not the common folks
should be privy to this conversation
yeah i'm gonna do it in the ancient
times never a real conversation yeah
this is for adults like when you hear
like all my latino friends when they
start like yelling at each other in
spanish
yeah um well they're good and they're
good at selling it like it's like they
really understand the language too
yeah i'm like i don't know it but it
sounds cool yeah it sounds like they
really learned it maybe
um everything about this is is awesome
there's a lot of great things to come
and and i feel like next week's gonna be
a banger oh yeah like that one's gonna
have some real violence some hardcore
yeah some some nautical and some fiery
violence and
the last thing i'll say is like would
damon and uh
and uh uh the horror uh
yes we got the names filled up here
yeah
and damon and miseria
like even her speech i was very much
touched by
and
that's just another thing that drives
home the whole thing that would him and
auto and otto um
cordless we're talking about
because the king
got to marry someone he loves
lost her and he still gets to choose
yeah who he wants for remarriage and
damon is just like
stuck with a woman he clearly does not
like yeah
and he can't even ha he can't even just
have her yeah
you could see that while he was being
very manipulative on a lot of many
accounts
and using her
there is that thing that seems like he
actually does like her and at the end of
the day if you were to choose who to
marry it'd be her yeah i mean you see
that dual life of like no they have a
real bond he actually cares about what
she has to say but also he's clearly
entwined in the game of thrones
and and i like that this
show the books i'm sure like these
stories bothered to give credence to
characters like that because i thought
her speech was really great and she's
like yeah i don't i don't care about
like statecraft and power i just don't
want to be afraid anymore i don't want
to be used for
everybody else's means like that's the
furthest reason from why i decided to be
with you and even that even that little
brief thing especially on the heels of a
love scene that people didn't seem very
pleased by last week
i i like that they got some good
emotional sparks this week but yeah guys
thank you so much for being here uh this
is uh an awesome awesome show uh you can
check us out on patreon thank you to
helix for sponsoring this video be sure
to leave a like subscribe
and hey let's do a patreon
lord brian of house perry how's it going
buddy just wanted to wish you well
winter has come for me as you can see by
the the the snowy backdrop of bleak
uncaring coldness but you my friend
you are the warmth in the realm the
warmth the realm needs
my friend you
no one but you
you brian perry will bring peace between
the realms you will unite the houses you
will be the king in the north and on the
iron throne the king of the entire realm
brian perry
but only
if you stay pledged this is the wall our
patreon that separates us from the
outside world from the people who wish
to destroy us brian
people seek to see our downfall but not
you
you're the best buddy
i hope you're doing well and we'll talk
soon
[Music]